[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Rick neisel he is the
former college coach and he was at a
couple of schools Washington Colorado
UCLA and now a college football analyst
for CBS Sports Rick where did all the
great college football teams
go uh kind of in the same direction that
the transfer portal went uh it it as
soon as they open those Gates players
were looking for playing time and for
compensation and that's why we don't
have uh a super
team who's it I guess there has to be a
couple of very very good teams oh
there's some really good teams and I
think both Michigan and Georgia are
really good teams the question is have
they played anybody that the committee
is going to say they're the best team
help me understand the Harbaugh
situation of how that like the crime
itself and sometimes it's the cover up
that's worse than the crime itself but
where where do you think this is headed
and how much of an advantage do you
think Michigan has received if this is
true based on all that I've kind of
gleaned from all the stuff written on it
uh it's an advantage I mean there's no
question that that's an advantage you
you you sit and listen to uh uh G Gordon
stallions you know
uh read his text and talk about uh Josh
gtis you know standing there and knowing
when the blitzes are coming and what
coverage it is Josh gtis the offensive
coordinator in 2021 Dan was the Frank
Royals Award winner he was the top
assisted coach of the year and now you
put two and two together you say he goes
to Miami in one year and's out he's
fired he doesn't even get to keep his
job after one
year what kind of Advantage did he have
the year before now now
that's here and yet now we're going to
wonder how much Advantage did he have
right uh so these are the kind of things
here are the things I think are Salient
points number one Harbaugh gets under
everybody's skin he just he enjoys it
he's a modern day Eddie Haskell he wants
to be that guy number two the
overzealous uh St stallions kid right
the O I mean he's super fan wanted to be
on the staff that's his dream they hired
him they didn't he didn't go and just
keep doing this they actually put him on
staff and number three and most
important he's sitting there standing
next to the coordinators in photographs
and video you don't stand I've given
field passes my whole life as a head
coach you know it's kind of like the The
Untold currency hey here's four field
passes and you guys stay down there and
enjoy the game but you don't get to
stand next to me you don't get to stand
next to the coordinator that guy
standing there next to the Denny with
the Denny's menu right next to these
coordinators and he's not ordering Grand
Slam breakfast he's telling them exactly
what's happening on the other side and
that's an advantage and and because of
the way Jim needles and gets under
people's skin they're going to come
after him how does this
end oh I don't think it ends I I think
they get through the season and I think
Jim goes off to the NFL if there's an
NFL team that will have him I thought it
would be perfect for him to be with the
Bears it kind of fits his personality
but I don't know what his relationship
is with Kevin Warren the former
commissioner but I wonder I don't know
if you can have a soft Landing in the
NFL if you have controversy in college
didn't uh trell prior uh wasn't he
punished you know when
the five game uh probation or five game
five game suspension that he got from
the NCA was
actually uh Roger Goodell yeah said that
those five games you had to sit in the
NFL too it's the only time I think in
the history that that has been the
penalties gone from one to the other
talking to Rick neisel CBS sports
college football analyst help me
understand what's going on at
USC wow it's coming uh apart but here's
the good news for the Trojans they won
they found a way to win they only have
they only have one loss and here comes a
game that's going to get everybody's
interest now certainly the Notre Dame
game should have gotten everybody's
interest uh but this is a game with
Washington coming to town that the home
crowd actually might carry him I just
don't know that Alex Grinch has enough
on the defensive side to get it done and
he's all that they have Alex Grinch is
all that they have a year ago they lived
on the turnover they were number one in
the country uh this year coming into a
week ago they were in the minus category
so that's the piece that they just don't
have uh and it looks like a lot of guys
that are kind of free agents where is
that you know that bonding and that's
been the gripe of those who are against
the transfer portal and all this free
access are we basing Caleb Williams
Heisman Trophy hopes on the Notre Dame
result that now we've just moved on from
him as you said they've only got one
loss they put up points they just can't
stop anybody why is Caleb Williams not
on that short list with the Heisman at
least according to you know DraftKings
if Caleb Williams ends up getting USC to
the conference Championship Game somehow
someway they have the two losses Notre
Dame is not a conference loss right uh
but if if they get to the Las Vegas and
win that game Caleb Williams will be
right back in that thing because that's
the only way they can do it is if he's
heroic uh and he obviously has the goods
to be just that when Colorado was
getting all this National publicity and
I said on the show what if they lose
like the next four or five where's
everybody going to be with this well
they've lost four of their last five so
where are we with Colorado and the
national
landscape my son was in that game he
coaches for UCLA and he said it was
really fun to have the stadium full so
whatever Prime is
doing what whatever Prime is doing it's
still Gathering the momentum that people
want to see uh he just doesn't have
enough players and and it's almost
refreshing Dan most coaches can't sit
there and say I don't have enough guys
they just can't do it Prime absolutely
not only does it but does it you know he
beats the drum it's about we got to get
better players he's going to give his
son days off yeah because because uh he
got hit so many times s well you got to
find other ways to do it most coaches
don't have enough players they figure
out ways to you know hide guys or or
come up with systems that don't put guys
in positions where they're going to be
exposed is not talented enough so that's
that's the uh marching orders for uh the
coordinators there at Colorado what's it
like to be on the field and they storm
the field whether you've won the game or
lost the game as a
coach well if you won the game it's the
greatest thing the world I mean just cuz
everybody's coming up and it's backs
slapping heaven right way to go way to
go coach that's uh a terrific uh deal if
you've lost a game you just want to get
the heck out of there because usually
people are coming by saying things that
are less uh fun to hear you just wanted
and and you want your play and really
what you do is you got your eyes out to
make sure your players aren't getting
involved in anything that's going to uh
be a problem for them so you're just
trying to get your guys off the field
but uh I the listen as a college
football fan which I count myself in
that number as much as I count myself in
any category of college football uh if
we could do it in an organized way and
know that everybody's going to get out
of there healthy it's the greatest thing
in the world those crowd staring
watching that thing in Kansas uh with
the Oklahoma game and then the goalpost
to go to Potter Lake which looked like a
nuclear
Wayside if some of those kids were
glowing in the Halloween party that
night you'll have to forgive them what
was the worst situation you were ever in
worst loss that you had where they
stormed the
field oh
uh I guess maybe in Nebraska in
96 uh we we Colorado went there and the
winner was going to play in the Big 12
championship game Nebraska won they
ended up losing to Texas and Texas uh
and that was the Year Steve sper won his
National Championship uh I think that
that because it was such a heartbreaking
loss we we lost I think 17 to 12 and uh
it's just one of those games where we
had chances down there should have
kicked field goals so I was and Nebraska
is the nicest fans in the world that
they weren't they didn't make me feel
like it was danger hey nice game coach
safe
travels sorry about the loss you done
any Christmas shopping yet Coach you're
going to have plenty of time now coach
yeah you got plenty of time great to
talk to you buddy thanks for joining us
blast Dan take care buddy that's Rick
niso yeah the Michigan situation with
Jim Harbaugh but I don't think it's that
easy that if all of a sudden season's
over no matter what happens and Michigan
moves on or he wants to move on I don't
think you can just make that transition
into the NFL with pending allegations
against you Terrell prior with the whole
tattoo situation at Ohio State he had to
carry that suspension into the NF well I
don't know if there are any other cases
of that